who else love s'mores I'm gonna be
honest if it has s'mores in the name I
am gonna try it even though I know full
well it's probably gonna taste nothing
like a s'mores more ice cream dare some
more M&Ms god it's Mario's sign me up
that's why when I see the Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man in ghostbusters all I
want is the giant Hershey bar guy in the
oversized graham cracker Ladd to show
off that's when we're having a party my
friends that's when
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the show that
asks questions about movies that others
are too afraid to ask or have too much
self-respect to ask but I'll let you
decide which one it is man in a summer
crammed full with movies there's one
that everyone is talking about
ghostbusters maybe not quite for the
right reasons I mean the original 1984
version is an undisputed classic holding
down a 97% fresh rating on Rotten
Tomatoes then fast forward to today
where the CGI filled all-female reboot
trailer is currently the most disliked
movie trailer in the history of YouTube
but let me say that again the most
disliked trailer in the history of
YouTube really really internet this is
so much worse than this are you going
bald huh no no you're getting fatter and
your hair doesn't realize it needs to
cover more faith okay hey I'm not
judging there is no accounting for taste
and I understand the comedic stylings of
Adam Sandler truly are transcendent Oh
comedy gold so the goal for today make a
video that you like at least slightly
better than the Ghostbusters trailer I'm
already starting at an advantage because
this video focuses on the original
Ghostbusters reminding you of that
happier era when watching a baby get
repeatedly put into life-threatening
situations was the epitome of
entertainment
truly when you think of the original
movie
yeah sure you had crossing streams and
the demonic David Bowie but the most
iconic image is none other than the Stay
Puft Marshmallow Man
it's a moment so brilliantly absurd it
became an instant classic and while
others were chortling away at Dan
Aykroyd's childhood memories of roasting
marshmallows by the fire at camp Wakanda
here's where my fierce brain went when I
first saw that scene that bit sure maybe
there's some fat Pat talking there but
hey it's all in the name of science
so today I'm answering the question
that's been on nobody's mind since 1984
how many calories are in the Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man and what would it mean
if I were to actually eat him now for
those of you who grew up not knowing who
you gonna call here's the skinny on our
chubbiest of bunnies in the original
Ghostbusters the team takes on an
ancient Sumerian demon named Gozer who's
haunting New York City as he do you know
the huge as part of the final showdown
goes or demands the heroes choose what
will destroy them and the rest of New
York City well everyone else tries to
keep their minds blank our good buddy
Dan Aykroyd accidentally imagines tried
to think of the most harmless thing the
Stay Puft Marshmallow Man and you can't
really blame him because images of Stay
Puft are sprinkled throughout the movie
when we see the eggs and Dana's
apartment explode and cook on the
counter a bag of Stay Puft Marshmallow
czar there on the counter with the rest
of the groceries and later in the film
we see a big mural for Stay Puft
Marshmallow Zahn the side of a building
with all those brand integrations poor
ray didn't stand a chance
subliminal advertising guys you gotta
put a hashtag spawn on those sorts of
things
sellouts anyway the great big
mallow-blaster appears Godzilla style
and starts pounding Upper Manhattan into
fluff hilarity ensues so let's figure
out just how much marshmallow action the
kaiju puff is packing to do this we need
to make some assumptions about the Stay
Puft Marshmallow mans contents let's
just say that he's made entirely of
marshmallow
normally I'd say he needs some kind of
musculoskeletal system to maneuver but
seriously he's a giant snack food
manifested out of Dan Akroyd
subconscious and compelled by a demon of
hell so we're gonna let normal Anatomy
slide on this one plus when he erupts
through ain't no viscera just a bunch of
marshmallow fluff so I think we're safe
now the first step in determining how
much of a caloric punch Stay Puft packs
is determining just how large he is in
the movie they give us a hint show by
100-foot Marshmallow Man but can we get
more exact absolutely in the DVD extras
for Ghostbusters mark Stetson the model
shop supervisor reveals that the scaled
size of the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man
was a hundred and twelve and a half feet
tall we can also compare that to the
surrounding buildings to confirm that
that's the right range so for once that
made my life a bit easier but from there
the calculations start to get a bit
trickier initially I tried to determine
the width of the Stay Puft Marshmallow
Man by looking at his scale compared to
the other landmarks in the movie there's
a shot where the ghostbusters are
looking down at Stay Puft as he walks
towards them and we can see that he's
about the width from the sidewalk to the
yellow centre lines of the street we
know that this is about 50 feet because
the streets de-puffed is walking on is
Central Park West in New York according
to the 1892 edition of the World Almanac
almost all avenues in New York City are
a hundred feet wide so Stay Puft is half
that but we'd still be missing depth and
the movie doesn't really show many good
shots from the side and more importantly
even if we're right about Stay Puft
being 50 feet wide at his widest how
wide is his head compared to the rest of
his body if you watch the series a lot
you'll know that I would usually account
for this sort of thing using pixel
measurements but Stay Puft is full of a
lot of unusual shapes and sizes so in
this case I'm using another measurement
that will do a better job of taking Stay
Puft Marshmallow man's irregular shape
and giving us workable numbers and that
measurement is BMI the statistic of BMI
was created in the 19th century and is
mostly used to measure the relative
thickness or thinness of a population by
measuring average weight across average
Heights and for our purposes it's
actually perfect because all it does is
calculate a ratio of height to width for
a human shaped object it doesn't matter
if the person is ripped or overweight or
happens to be composed entire
sugar and looking at the marshmallow man
he's not just a bunch of cylindrical
marshmallow stacked together
he's got folds and girth to them he's
much more human than he is purely
geometric so knowing that take a look at
this chart of body shapes and their
associated BMI as Stay Puft is round and
has relatively thick limb from a purely
scientific perspective they pumped shape
indicates that he would have a very high
BMI and judging by the figures of BMI of
40 is a good estimate perhaps even a
slightly conservative one hey we will
have no candy shaming on this channel
okay but now that we have a heightened
the projected BMI for the Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man we can calculate how
much he would weigh or more accurately
we can determine how much a human being
his size would weigh and then go from
there
the formula for body mass index states
that BMI is equal to 703 times a
person's weight in pounds divided by
their height in inches square stay-puft
height is 100 12.5 feet which translates
to 1,350 inches when we square the
height and then multiply the BMI of 40
by that number and then divide the
result by 703 we have isolated weight of
one hundred and three thousand six
hundred and ninety eight pounds but now
before you rage in the comments no
obviously he doesn't weigh 103 thousand
pounds like I said that would be the
weight of the Stay Puft Man Man if the
say Puft Marshmallow Man were actually
just a human of marshmallow man size one
you get it what we're looking for is the
marshmallow man so we need to convert
his weight from this figure what he
would weigh as a human to what he would
weigh as a marshmallow to do that we
need to know what the density of a human
and a marshmallow actually are the
density of a human being does vary but
for heavier set people it's usually
around one point zero one grams per
milliliter now we can adjust the weight
of one hundred three thousand six
hundred ninety eight pounds to it's
marshmallow equivalent by converting
human density to the density of a
marshmallow which is 0.21 grams per
milliliter about a fifth of the density
of a human so doing all the math that
means that Stay Puft Marshmallow Man
actually weighs in at 21,000 561 pounds
or about 9500 kilograms which is
actually surprisingly light for a
building crushing monster for
perspective that's lighter than a
typical school
so having him destroyed buildings may be
a bit of a stretch he's still a giant
marshmallow even at that enormous of a
size his squishy Stay Puft Miss would
actually just puff off of most well-made
buildings I hear you in the comments
saying geez Matt man I came here because
I want to eat an ancient Sumerian demon
and not talk about school bosses and
yeah that's valid I totally understand
your desire to eat an ancient Sumerian
so now that we know how much he weighs
figuring out the number of calories he
contains is really no sweat for
reference I used the nutrition facts of
crafts jet puffed marshmallows because
something tells me they're not all that
different which claims to have a hundred
calories for every four marshmallows or
30 grams 20 grams of which is pure sugar
when we convert the weight of Stay Puft
in pounds to grams and then multiply
that by the number of calories per gram
we get our whopping total the Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man comes out to be thirty
two point six million calories get ready
to hit that Pilates class a few hundred
thousand times if you wanted to consume
that many calories you'd have to down
about two hundred and twenty eight
thousand cans of coca-cola or eat 2.7
million peanut M&Ms or have sixty-two
thousand seven hundred Big Mac meals
from the Golden Arches considering that
the average human life is twenty-seven
thousand three hundred and seventy-five
days you would practically have to have
that Big Mac meal three times a day
every day for the rest of your life to
get to that level of caloric intake
which in turn begs the question what
about burning him off well a good rule
of thumb is that a typical person will
burn a hundred calories per mile of
walking so that would translate to you
walking 326 thousand miles to work off
your marshmallow man binge if that
sounds like a lot you don't know the
half of it the circumference of the
earth is just about 25,000 miles so you
would have to walk around the entire
globe thirteen times to burn off that
Sumerian demon you consumed man knew I
should have ordered off the lighter menu
a Caesar salad Titan was calling my name
considering the average caloric intake
for a man is about 2,000 a day that's
nearly 44 years worth of calories in a
single serving hungry why wait eat a
marshmallow man you'll be set for life
and talk about your sugar rush
100 foot tall marshmallow man is the
equivalent of six point five two million
grams of sugar that's seven American
tonnes the equivalent of a fully grown
adult African elephant made entirely of
sugar it's nearly one and a half million
Oreo cookies single stuffed which let's
be honest is clearly inferior to double
stuffed so it's actually a million
Double Stuf Oreos you may have also seen
studies about how much humans have
increased their sugar intake over the
course of our history it's estimated to
have risen six hundred percent over the
last hundred forty years we now consume
130 pounds or 60,000 grams of sugar
every year which admittedly is a lot but
even in the face of this huge increase
of sugar intake Stay Puft represents a
hundred and eight years of constantly
shoving sugar into your face so needless
to say the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man
doesn't seem to be part of a balanced
diet so the big question of the day
still remains could you eat him
technically the answer is yes but the
fine print would say not for very long
the problem is with the sugar
toxicologists believed that a lethal
dose of sugar for a human being is about
15 grams per kilogram of weight I say
believe because these are estimates
apparently it's pretty hard to find test
subjects who are willing to eat sugar
until they die go figure
sometimes it feels like it come close to
that though sorry that's fat Pat talking
again for a hundred and fifty pound
adult that lethal dose would be between
two and two and a half pounds of sugar
or about 1000 grams which all things
considered isn't all that much if you
are committed to eating the Beast he
would kill you six thousand five hundred
times over before you were done which
means in an ironic twist the scariest
thing about Stay Puft isn't his physical
force remember he's punching with less
strength and density than a school bus
and it isn't crossing the streams it's
in fact his sugar content forget getting
stepped on he would literally kill you
before you nod his toe off but hey
that's just a theory a film theory and
cut but before I sign off do you want to
win $50,000 how about winning up to
$2,000 every day for the rest of July it
sounds like
it's a scheme but it's not I was
selected to host a new reality
competition series called the runner for
the entire month of July and you guys
you at home have the opportunity to win
a bunch of cash basically the runner is
a cross-country manhunt as a secret
Super Soldier tries to make his way
across the United States without getting
caught if he does it he wins $500,000
but this is where you come in it's up to
five chaser teams and you guys online
helping them to track him down and win
that money for yourself by solving Clues
delivered live by me during the
broadcast at the start of each day you
guys are theorists you're totally gonna
crush this you win money by doing brain
puzzles that's it so you interested I
hope so cause it's legitimately really
cool it's a new series not on YouTube
but on go 90 posted by yours truly an
executive produced by Jason Bourne and
batfleck himself Matt Damon and Ben
Affleck yeah this is legit the chase
officially begins tomorrow July 1st and
to kick things off the show is giving
away $50,000 to lucky viewers $50,000
tomorrow so you'll definitely want to
tune in on day one to do that you'll
want to go to go nine decom slash a
runner or download the go 90 app to
watch the show don't worry it's all free
and links are in the description first
episode starts at noon East Coast time
or 9:00 a.m. Pacific July first
from there I'll be coming to you live to
explain more on how to win but again
everything is totally free
none of this affects the flow of
episodes or us doing regular GT live
live streams it's just really a chance
for me to live out my bucket list
being a game show host and giving you
guys the chance to win easy to win cash
all while participating in a pretty
cutting-edge show where you guys over
social media are tracking down a
super-soldier stealth in its way across
the country so please consider checking
it out live every day of July starting
at noon eastern on ian pacific and that
said let the chase begin